ever since dolly the cloned sheep
emerged from the lab in 1997 Europeans
have been skeptical today a big majority
of em eps were with them beefing up a
partial cloning ban to cover all farm
animals their offspring and imported
cloned food and feed voyage au po tay
tay vitara say Verde Philly Martin
futuro SI votre fille Serrano lake ave e
dalla Bora Torrio deep ok company a
kafir a no-profit issue Lagos repeal
dvorn a snitch Tom wise again now diese
angstrom does thus clonin let's English
Venice I'm a rich dish from soon yet
than off by mention and give ended yet
European Commission wanted to ban
cloning five key farm species and the
import of live clones but not their
offspring or cloned food the Centers of
clones are conceived through
conventional methods and therefore
create neither food safety Lord animal
welfare concerns what about the
possibilities that cloning and
scientific advance can lead to an
improvements in the animal welfare not
to opponents who argue fewer than ten
percent of cloned animals survive and
many of those that do are deformed or
die young we're partners clone of a hop
nisht the martin is nisht very soft for
church then conveyor of conventional
advisor our psyche terrorizing relied on
kind in mangalore does Ladakh India
sukin finished design next step a final
round of talks with member states before
it becomes law
my